is it possible that simply changing the
way you visualize can dramatically
change your reality in this video we're
diving into the compelling world of
visualization this isn't just about
daydreaming or idle fantasies it's a
practical powerful approach to achieving
personal and professional Milestones
we're talking about a technique that has
a potential to reshape your life's
trajectory from Career Success to
personal wellbe the stakes are more than
just Dreams they're about the reality
that you live every day mastering this
visualization technique can be the key
to unlocking unprecedented levels of
success and fulfillment in your life
imagine transforming your aspirations
into tangible achievements simply by
harnessing the power of your mind but
here's the Intriguing part there's a
specific way to visualize that many
people don't know about it's a Twist
that can exponentially increase the
effectiveness of this technique what is
this unique approach and how can it
shift your reality stay with us as we
reveal the secrets to visualization that
can turn your dreams into reality hey
it's EV Carmichael and I watch these
videos every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goals kickstarting your day with a
blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
# believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you so today let's learn how you can
visualize enjoy thoughts are everywhere
and we pull thoughts into our mind and
we build pictures or images in our mind
okay what we want to understand is
that's a non-physical side of our s
that's doing that if I can build an
image of something in my mind I'm quite
capable of building a physical replica
of it in my world so if I build an image
of me as a happy relaxed
person I can live like that if I build
an image of myself as being prosperous I
can become prosperous so if we think
Rich we will be rich absolutely we're
already rich just short of
money okay those of us that like to
acquire more money and or happiness or
whatever we we see success those of us
that want to reach the goals that we've
set for ourselves we do it first by well
the first thing you do is sit down and
decide what you want if it's money you
want how much money lots of money well
nobody knows how much lots of is so
you've got to be specific okay you write
down on a card exactly what you want and
you carry that card around and read it
often now this is what I learned in this
book Think and Grow Rich and it's what I
teach in the seminars I'll teach people
how to set goals but you decide exactly
what you want and then you start to
think now you're going to have thoughts
come to your mind of why you can't get
it mhm you have the ability in your
conscious mind to reject that idea kick
it out of your mind thinking of why you
can't do something is never going to do
you any good and keep thinking until you
start to think of thoughts of how you
can do
it and the way will be shown to you it
comes in the form of images in our mind
think of how you can and not why you
can't rule number two is obliterate your
old identity with Jens and Cheryl do you
think we have to go through an identity
shift in order to see money differently
and to be able to receive it differently
I think you do absolutely that's a
really great way to go at it so what was
your you know the key words around your
identity with money when you didn't have
much versus the key words that you would
speak about within yourself or what
money is once you started to unlock more
money well it wasn't necessarily around
identity my words because I did have two
very serious mantras um but but there
was a lot of visualizing myself with
money and like I I wrote about buying
the Audi and you are a bad and like I'm
not the kind of person who drives an
Audi are you kidding me like and like
almost feeling like this the guy who
like test drove it with me and be like
get out of here I know who you are you
can't afford this exactly so um so but
my mantras really like and before I
started make money I said I can't afford
it to pretty much anything you could
throw at me my first words out of my
mouth were I can't afford it and I what
are we doing when we we're saying that
whether it's true or not true we are
buying into an identity as somebody who
can't afford stuff we are also proving
it you know what you speak you want to
prove because you want to be right and
it is sort of the foundation of your
reality so when I say I can't afford it
a hundred times a day I'm subconsciously
pulling in proof like look at the car
I'm driving I'm living in an alley like
I make this much money a year I'm I'm
building all the found AAL blocks to
prove that I can't afford it and that
becomes my reality and then that becomes
my I like to call it familiarity Zone
because Comfort zones are not
comfortable interesting right so so then
I'm just proving it over and over and
over and that becomes my reality and
then to shift out of that um literally
means to obliterate your reality and
your identity right so that's why it's
like an explosion it's like you have to
have like a death an explosion a bomb
almost to go lot it does and it's
killing off your old identity and this
is why I'm going to totally go off on a
segue here but this is why like the
number one question I get at my talks is
what do you do when the people closest
to you don't support your growth and the
main reason they don't support it
because you're killing off the person
they love oh man I mean think about that
like you're changing who you are and
they're comfortable with who you are and
they feel that's their reality too is is
caught up in who you are being so when
you decide to change you're killing off
their buddy or their whatever and you're
screwing up their reality because you
fit into theirs rule number three is
stop playing the program with Bruce
Lipton you know the movie The Matrix
yeah well it's not science fiction folks
The Matrix The Matrix is a documentary
what do you mean documentary I said
what's the premise oh the premise is
everybody's been programmed I go well
that's a fact of life every human has
been programmed it's the way nature
designs how you can become a member of a
family in a community okay and I go so
everybody's been programmed I go yeah
but oh in the movie you could take a red
pill and get out of the
program
oh most of you actually have taken the
red pill and you did get out of the
program not necessarily for a long time
but you stepped out I said what was that
red pill you
ready when you fell in love with
somebody I go what do you mean I go
your life was blah blah blah blah blah
blah you meet
somebody 24 hours later your attitude is
oh life's beautiful man I love life food
is great you know the music's great the
sex is
wonderful everything is great I'm so in
love I
go what how'd you do that after blah
blah blah blah in just 24 hours
science has recognized that when you
fall in love you stop
thinking you stay what is called mindful
you are what is called staying present
what was the point you stopped thinking
and you kept your Consciousness right
there in the front why well if you've
been waiting for this person your whole
life and then they show up this is not
the time to think and disconnect this is
time to be there so you stop thinking
then what you stop playing the program
first time in your life stop playing it
dead right out I say what happened well
now you're creating from what not
subconscious creating from the conscious
what's that wishes and desires so what
is the honeymoon heaven on Earth like
o guess what the jokey part here is you
could have that every day it's your damn
program that takes you away from it it's
not that you can't have it all you have
to do is stop playing the program and
then you start you got the control back
again and the issue about that
is we can change those
programs and we can take power back by
rewriting programs what if your programs
actually reflected the same thing that
you have as wishes and Desires in your
conscious mind think about for one
second what if my conscious mind's
wishes and desires were also programs in
my subconscious mind you
ready whether you're thinking or whether
you're
awake uh guess
what you're going to be going to the
same wishes and desires all of a sudden
it says what does that mean it says
simply this it says that when you stop
thinking you play the you are playing
from wishes and desires when when you
are thinking you play from program but
if your program has the same wish and
desire then it doesn't make a difference
if you're thinking or you're not
thinking why you're still going to the
same place and I say so what would that
be oh I'll give you an example I'm doing
it right now what am I doing I couldn't
get a relationship off the ground for
nearly 50 years until I
rewrote those dysfunctional programs
that I got from my father and once I
rewrote them I was now available to have
a love
experience and I met my partner Margaret
and guess what 28 years of everyday
honeymoon every day I always joke every
stinking day is
honeymoon and I love it and I go why I
live in a world like you do it's crazy
all that stuff is going on out there
does it come into my particular life
absolutely not why it's not in my cre
Creative Vision none of that stuff is
there am I in the world yeah but it's
not necessarily not participating in all
the other crazy people stuff why because
those programs that would have engaged
me have been
Rewritten and now I have the power and I
say so what did I do well I chose
honeymoon yeah what was that wishes and
desires hi I'm Bruce lion author of the
bestselling books the biology belief
spontaneous ution and the honeymoon
effect I'm here to thank Evan carmichel
for featuring me on his YouTube channel
and I want to let you know that Evan is
giving away links where you can watch
the First episodes of my special Gaia
series entitled in a revolution for free
evidence making this offer to thank you
for watching this video you will find
the links in the description section
below thank you rule number four is
dream with the lid off with Mel Robbins
give yourself
permission to dream with the lid off
this is really important and the reason
why this is important is because I
guarantee you that right now you are not
even allowing yourself to fully dream or
think about or set goals that are truly
aligned with what you deeply want in
your heart that you aren't even able to
manifest properly because you're not
even honest with yourself about what you
you actually want this is a really
common thing because you're allowing
your self-doubt you are allowing your
fears your anxiety your insecurity
you're allowing where you are to dictate
and limit where you want to go and so
step one super important you must allow
yourself give yourself permission to
start dreaming with the lid off now the
scientific reason why this is so
important is because you have a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activity system I write about the RAS
for short the reticular activity system
extensively in the high five habit the
RAS is a filter in your mind and you can
do simple things that change the
structure of that filter in fact the
filter in your mind the RS is always
changing so one thing that you can do in
order to teach yourself how to dream
with the L off is to adopt a simple
habit every single morning I do a very
simple thing I write down five things
that I want that's it when I start my
day after I get up on the alarm rings I
make my bed I pull on my exercise clo I
set an intention I highfive myself in
the mirror I then go out into the
kitchen I crack open my high- five
journal and then inside the journal
there are prompts that walk me through
the steps of visualizing and the first
prompt is dream with the lid off set
your spirit free write down five things
every morning that you want and this is
important because when you get what you
want out of your head and you physically
put them on a piece of paper research
shows that you're 42% more likely to
achieve those goals simply by writing
them down that's pretty cool secondly
your mind is paying attention and when
you take deliv liberate action and you
write down what you want you are
signaling to your brain that you deserve
to have these things you are signaling
to your brain that you do want those
things you're not just going to think
about them these are things that matter
to you and that helps train your mind to
allow you to let the desires flow
through you because right now you're not
manifesting properly because you're not
even allowing yourself to dream with the
lid off so that's step number one you're
going to start writing down five things
that you want every single morning as a
way to train your mind to let you dream
freely rule number five is think
positively with Dr Tara wart abundance
is basically about thinking positively
it's about believing that the world is a
good place that there's enough out there
for everyone that we're not in
competition for resources and that if
somebody else does well that doesn't
mean badly for us that if we give
something to someone or help someone
with something that that's a good thing
that it generates more positivity and
that somehow you know the that that will
come back to you at some point and
interestingly it um correlates to the
strongest gearing of the brain that we
have for our survival as a species which
is called loss aversion yes so um that
means that the psychological effect of
avoiding loss is about twice as powerful
as the psychological effect of the
equivalent gain or reward and the
easiest way to explain that is um if you
walked from the parking lot to your
studio this morning and you found $50 on
the floor on your way in you'd be
probably pleasantly surprised that you
found $50 you might keep it you might
give it to charity um but by the time
you you know you're in the studio and
you've started thinking about recording
you would have forgotten about that
$50 if you walked from your car across
the parking lot and realized by the time
you got to the studio that you'd lost
$50 out of your pocket you'd be mad at
yourself you'd go back out to the the
parking lot to see if you could find it
you might even go back out there more
than once to check and you might still
be thinking about that at the end of the
day so that's just an example of how the
same loss or gain has more powerful
effect if we lose and so psychologically
um anything like feeling excluded or
isolated or treated unfairly or feeling
like you don't have the same
opportunities as somebody else has that
really strong effect on your on your
brain um and so we have to work doubly
hard to go against that because it is
something that helped us to survive in
evolution but
it's I was going to say it's not helpful
in the modern world but to be honest I
will say it's not a way to live a life
um you know it's a
very because I believe the way you think
determines your life if you believe that
everybody's out there in competition
there isn't enough out there for
everyone that you've got to like fight
to get your bit and rule number six the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is refine your intention with J
Shetty people often ask me about my
meditation routine or my morning routine
I meditate for 2 hours a day I have done
for the last 13 years and one of my
favorite meditation practices that I do
which is the smallest and shortest part
of my meditation is that I refine my
intention what I mean by that is every
day I write down thoughts in my mind
that are either weeds or
seeds seeds are ones that I want to grow
seeds are things that I want to plant
because they're full of love compassion
empathy
kindness and the weeds are greed
negativity manipulation power control so
so every day I'm literally gardening My
Heart by pulling out every weed and
plucking out every weed that I no longer
want to plant in my house because guess
what weeds end up looking like seeds
often in our
life the weeds and the seeds look
exactly the same when they start
growing and that's one of the biggest
challenges we're wired for
generosity but we're educated for
greed and we're so deeply wired for
generosity but everything's trying to
pull us away from that we've been told
two lies in our
life the first lie is you're
nothing you're not worth anything you
haven't got anything that's the first
lie the second lie we've all been
told is you can be
anything it's a lie it's not
true the way we're
wired defines what we can do with that
wire
ring and therefore the truth
is you can't be anything you
want but you can be everything you are
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight our favorite lessons from the
video that will inspire you to remember
what you learned today and actually
apply them the worksheet will also give
you space to write down what your key
takeaways are and your specific plan of
action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you
there what are some things that people
can do to you know always take their
belief to the next level what are some
of the things that you're doing
consistently to consistently build that
belief so so they can get it to that
that level where it's like until it
becomes their reality that what their
goals are yeah I mean I know we got a
pop but but two quick things one is to
start to surround yourself more with the
people who are embodying that belief
right so and whatever it's not just
believe in yourself whatever you want
more you want more courage be around
more courageous people you know if I
want to be a better parent I'm G to hang
out with my parents more if I want to be
a better Visionary I'm going to hang out
with you know Steve Jobs more and and I
can't meet Steve Jobs but there there's
enough of his content out there that you
can be around it and learn it uh so
that's step number one if you love Tyler
great if Tyler makes you feel like
things are possible if Tyler gives you
more courage or commitment to Excellence
follow him subscribe to his shows be
have Tyler if Tyler was living with you
every day you're gonna grow and you're
gonna get more courageous and have more
commit Excellence so so have him live
with you by watching all his stuff
constantly so I'm around Elon Musk and
Steve Jobs and Oprah winfy and these
people every day it's what I needed when
I was 19 and it's still what I need
today at 40 and and that's why I do what
I do so step number one is is to
radically change your environment to to
have the people from from the things
that are on your wall to the what's in
your Instagram feed your YouTube feed
from the from the clothes that you wear
to the the thing that you're drinking
right like all of it is is is a reminder
of who you want to be and then so that's
that that gives you the framework to
start to feel it more step two is and
there's only two steps you got to do
something right like you could watch
Tyler all day long and get courage great
but now you gotta Tyler's not gonna come
and make the call for you Tyler's not
gonna come and launch that drink company
for you Tyler's not gonna come and right
so you have to do it right but what what
Tyler can do what I can do what whoever
can do is give you that little bit of
motivation that little bit of courage to
then take the step and build momentum so
you need that motivation daily because
you might be super fired up and inspired
today awesome you're going to wake up
tomorrow and go back to not having as
much courage and confidence and belief
and so you need that as part of your
daily routine to get you inspired to the
point where you then where you then take
the action that you're afraid to do
every human being is a
Creator and they are creating their life
and we don't
know for many of us we did not know that
that was the case and we are creating
our life through our thoughts so it's
not that our thoughts are powerful it's
that we are powerful and so when we
focus on a thought and we really hold
that Focus that thought will manifest in
our life and so we create our own life
through our thoughts and through the
mind the Mind our mind
is super super super
powerful yeah for good or For Worse yes
so for example um we can talk about what
we want and we will manifest that you
know and so some people they just see
the abundance in the world you know
that's all that they see they don't they
don't see any lack they just see
abundance and everything seems to go
right for them everything falls into
place for them they invest in this and
at skyrockets and they they buy a house
in this place and that suburb goes crazy
and it's like everything they touch
turns to Gold but it's because they have
a mindset that is toward wealth and
abundance and they don't have a mindset
toward luck and we have a lack mindset
when we say things like I'm broke I
don't have
enough um I don't have enough to pay my
bills
and you see whatever we say is what our
life will be and so if we are saying I
don't have enough money then by law of
attraction we will not have enough money
we will continue to not have enough
money so what we have to do is we need
to speak about what we want and we need
to talk about for example if it's money
or if it's health or if we're not
feeling really great then we can talk
about what it feels like to be really
well instead of talking about not being
well right because if we're talking
about not being well we're attracting
more of that more of that more of that
right and so that's
basically law of attraction I mean it is
so wonderful and it's so intricate and
the more that
you the more that it becomes a part of
your life the more you see the the
little kind of twists and turns
synchronicities yeah like for for
example if if if you saying you I'm so
overwhelmed there's just so much going
on at the moment and I can't get on top
of things and I'm just
overwhelmed guess what guess what's
coming more overwhelming more if you
speak the language of money you usually
make more of it man this one is so true
there's a bunch of words they use in fin
that take people from really really rich
to outside of the loop entirely most of
us don't speak the language of finance
and I think that's on purpose I think
people in finance do not want you to
know the secrets to wealth because that
makes it easier for them to keep it but
there are so many terms ibida Roi cash
onh return expense ratio the list goes
on and on and on actually there's a
whole article here on it if you want it
but if you actually want to get real
wealth you have to learn the main terms
it's pretty easy to do actually you
could take a couple courses on YouTube
but this was actually told to me by one
of the wealthiest Partners uh at Goldman
Sachs they came down in the beginning
and did a little lunch and learn with us
when I was at the firm and we were
asking a bunch of questions and he was
using jargon eida for instance and I
remember one of the people in the room
raised their hands and they said what
does the term iida mean can you explain
that and he kind of looked at the person
with like snoody Goldman air as did and
said I don't know how you got a job at
this firm without speaking the language
of money that term exactly the language
of money and he said you go find the
answer to that I'm not here to be your
dictionary and it was such a perfectly
Goldman response but actually he was
right so it always stuck with me learn
the terms then you can make the cash the
words you use really are like a context
or a framework or a stained glass window
on the way you see the world I mean
here's a game gamechanging Insight you
see the world not as it is you see the
world as you are you see the world
through a lens and your language forms
that lens of belief I mean your lens of
belief and your personal filter on
reality is not really a true filter on
reality it's just the filter on reality
that has formed as a result of all the
words you've picked up from the moment
you were born so when you were a little
baby your mom and your dad used the
language that they were taught when they
were kids to use and if they use the
language of victimitis and if they use
the language of victimhood like well you
know you can't do this I hate this I'm
tired of this money doesn't grow on
trees be ordinary if you're successful
you'll be hated all that messaging that
we pick up from our parents and the
media and the world around us and our
peers the little kids that we used to
play with in the playground or the
friends that we had as
teenagers that will either Lift us up or
tear us down so I guess what I'm trying
to say and hopefully I'm making the
point clearly for you but we see the
world through this personal filter and a
lot of this personal filter that drives
our performance and our behavior is
really constructed from the words that
we've picked up and then the words we
are taught to use and so the right angle
turn for you to create exponential
energy mindset productivity creativity
results in the world results in your
life comes down to in part A really
intelligent use of your words and like I
said at the beginning of this Mastery
session most people are really
unconscious about their words and that's
why most people are not getting rare ER
results so what are some of the words I
encourage you to shift from well don't
talk about what you hate to do talk
about what you love to do don't talk
about problems talk about opportunities
don't talk about what makes you tired
talk about what makes you
inspired don't talk about your past talk
about your future don't talk about what
broke you your heart talk about what
opened your heart don't talk about what
disp Spirits you talk about what you are
fueled by don't talk about the things
within your life that are not working
talk about the things in your life that
are working don't talk talk about your
pain talk about your pleasure and you
know if I if I were sitting with you
right now coaching you I mean I am
coaching you and what I would encourage
you to do as soon as I finish this
Mastery session is pull out your journal
and if you're not journaling please
start journaling because journaling is a
ritual you want to install into your
Days Joan deian said this I don't know
what I think until I write it
down think about that I don't know what
I think until I write write it down and
so in your Journal after this Mastery
session pull out a fresh page and draw a
line down the center of the page and
write about the language of victimhood
and the language of leadership leader
ship and start to write down all the
words you use and the sentences you
employ that really are speaking that are
really victims speak and then in the
other column I want you to start writing
down the language of leadership the
language that as of today you will be
committed to using so that you start to
use the language of someone who's world
class and I've given you some examples
but doing that exercise will make it
really clear and as you know Clarity
breeds Mastery bottom line is this you
are built to be a leader you are not
constructed to be a victim and once you
get your words right you are going to
start noticing daily shifts in your
energy your focus your momentum your
confidence and your output and when you
start getting those words right you
start lifting your professional life
your personal life to a whole new level
of wow and guess what that is what you
are meant to do our affirmations a total
waste of time what about declarations
you know declaring that something is
real that it is what about I promise and
you don't really believe the promise so
let's understand something first and
foremost and you know is it's
John think about affirmations like my
good friend Dr John D Martini does and
in my discussions with him he's got one
of the best um ideas around that I like
it's an affirmation is really all about
affirming something in one's mind so an
affirmation isn't about stating
something that you don't believe as a
truth no it's taking something that you
may not believe and affirming it in your
mind so that you start to believe it and
you start to behave in ways in alignment
with what is that you believe so think
about this were you born with any
beliefs
no so other people's beliefs in most
cases were given to you right me too
through parents teachers siblings uh TV
things we read things we we watched Etc
and so when I started using affirmations
back when I was
19 it started off with things like I'm
so happy and grateful for the fact that
I am now achieving all my goals and
dreams now at the time I wasn't when I
would say
that I would hear this little voice in
my head going bull that's not true
but I was also taught to understand that
that voice was that critical voice that
we all have almost like a a little you
know critical person you know sitting on
your shoulder you know trying to remind
you that you're not good enough not
worthy enough not smart enough Etc and I
was taught to say next just take that
idea and go next and then go I'm so
happy and grateful for the fact that I
am achieving all my goals and dreams the
repetition side of affirmations with
emotion
activates okay electrical signals in
your brain right when the electrical
signals in your brains are firing they
call them neurons that fire together the
affirmation wire together now why is
that important well if I don't believe
something like I'm so happy and grateful
for the fact that I'm achieving every
one of my goals and dreams and yet I
repeat it I emotionalize it I feel it
and I say yes this is what I want to
believe this is what I'm choosing to
believe I'm deliberately and
consciously creating my belief system
well why not do that deliberately
instead of believing all the that's out
there right that people believe because
of their experiences so what happens is
if we fire these neurons enough in our
brain and we wire them enough in our
brain they go from ious effort I don't
believe it to well maybe I do believe it
to I believe it to how do I behave in
ways that I believe that's how we
develop our beliefs that's how we
develop our identity that's how we
develop our character I think we've all
experienced those synchronicities where
you're thinking about something or you
have an intention and all of a sudden
you start to see reality kind of conform
itself around you in some way and you're
not going anywhere to get it uh somehow
it seems to be coming to you and there's
a very direct correlation between energy
and reality so when you start to
synchronize your energy to a possibility
that exists in the quantum field and you
have a coherent brain there's a very
very specific signal that we can send
out that's very very coherent and
clear and when we match that brain
coherence with heart coherence
it is the heart that acts as a magnet
and draws the experience back to us so
the thought being electrical charge and
the feeling being the magnetic charge
and how you think and how you feel
broadcasts information into the quantum
field and I think whatever we broadcast
into the field is our experiment with
Destiny so we either create from the
field or we create from matter and if we
create from matter as bodies local in
space and time and three-dimensional
reality we have to move through space to
get what we want we have to move back
and forth to work and drive there uh to
manifest our dreams and in creating in
threedimensional reality takes time and
it takes
energy sometimes uh people get so lost
in reality they forget what their dreams
were because there's too much time
between cause the thought and effect the
experience that's what separation does
in three-dimensional reality creating
from the field and getting Beyond
yourself your associations to everything
physical and known and being able to
enter
through a small door the eye of the
needle the quantum field passing through
that eye of the needle as pure
Consciousness and connecting to a field
and teaching people how to create from
the field instead of from matter
connected to that unified field
uh to Source energy when they create
from source and they're Connected To
Source and source is the cause that
creates matter the effect if we create
from Source connected to it from the
field instead of from matter we don't
have to go anywhere now to get what we
want we begin to draw the experiences to
us so by
combining heart coherence with brain
coherence now we have a Wi-Fi signal and
all we have to do is synchronize our
energy to some intention with some
emotion and tune in to the energy the
future and the longer you're conscious
of this energy the more you draw your
future to you and if you keep practicing
it every day it's going to become
familiar to you and all of a sudden that
will be your natural energy and when you
change your energy you change your life
and the more coherent the signatures
electromagnetically the more refined the
experience
we have when you think a deliberate
thought of what you
want um then Law of Attraction will
employ the universe and all people
circumstances and events to move you to
what you've asked for and to move what
you've asked for to you and so if if if
you think about that there is just
action would be really really hard for
you to reach all of the people
circumstances and events manipulate all
of them to receive what you want and if
you really reflect well on your life and
things that have happened in your life
you kind of see that actually that
happened for me all I did was move to
here or all I did was move to there and
I received what I wanted thought creates
all of the appearances in the world and
thought creates everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful right and
what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is
manifesting their day every single day
we're doing it um we are not aware of
course necessarily of thoughts but
thoughts come we energize them and then
they will manifest unless we cancel that
thought out um with another thought with
a thought that contradicts it but I
remember Lester levenson would say every
single thought
manifests and I just thought that was
incredible I had known the secret for
years and years and years and Lester
levenson was a real master um and he
said every single thought manifests and
I was just wow that's how powerful F
they are
so so thoughts are your
superpower to be do and
have what you want to experience and
have and do in your life and and so if
you ask um an athlete or if you talk to
a coach a really brilliant coach right
of a sports team then you will find that
visualization and these principles that
I'm talking about are a big part of
their training
that they have to be they have to see
themselves winning the game they have to
see themselves winning the match there
is a really incredible tennis player
that's a very big
fan um a champion tennis player that's a
really big fan of the secret who uses
the secret this is what he does he sees
that he has won the match before he
walks out onto that court and and it's
the same for um for teams it's the same
for athletes in the Olympic Games
running around race and seeing that
they've won yes they run the race but
what has them win the race is that they
saw themselves winning before they even
got on the starting block and they saw
it and believed it and felt it and so
they just everything lined up for them
in the perfect way they drew the perfect
Lane everybody else was was moved in
exactly the right position and they got
a really great start and they won the
race
and so thought is just so so powerful so
athletes but also do you know the
astronauts in the Apollo um program did
visualization before they went to the
moon and they visualized Landing back on
Earth safely and so that's how important
V visualiza visualization is just
thought in pictures by the way it's it's
it's still thought it's just the same
thing okay it's just thought
pictures so if you took a person who had
zero
resistance and you locked them in a room
no if you took a person that had zero
resistance that person thought about
what they wanted zero resistance lock
them in a room what they wanted will
come to them the universe will move
people circumstances and events and
bring that right to them it must it
absolutely must because if you have no
resistance you have Unleashed a law that
just cannot be stopped and so you will
manifest it will come to you I set a
goal in
1973 I set a goal that I was going to
build a company that operate all over
the
world I had uh left the Nel K
Corporation and decided that I was going
to do this because I didn't agree with
the way they were doing it people
weren't really learning it fast enough
uh they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them so I decided I would leave
and start my own company and I wrote
down I'd build a company and operated
all over the world I got a call last
night from Mikey about 9:00 something
like that and um she told me that we
were now in every country in the
world now think of
that we had a broadcast going on here at
10:00 this morning some of you be
familiar with it some of you may have
been on it and
um that broadcast had attracted
thousands literally thousands of
people from every country in the world
the goal was
reached that move meant this is really
accurate today we're only limited by
weakness of attention and Poverty of
imagination well my imagination was
pretty well exercised I don't have any
difficulty building huge ideas in my
mind and just figuring out how to do it
now stay with me
here the thing that stopping you from
taking the risk that you want to take is
called a terror
barrier the way I'm going to explain
this to you I come up with sitting in a
restaurant I remember it was at a
Holiday In Restaurant it was at Dixie
and uh just south of the 401 Highway in
Toronto a man asked me if I would meet
with him he had a problem and um I was
going to show him how he could solve the
problem and he explained it so I took a
pen and some paper and what I'm going to
show you here is essentially what I
showed
him now look at this for a moment there
is the process you go through when
you're in a risk taking vibration you go
from
bondage to
reason to the terror barrier and then to
Freedom you go from
bondage to
reason to the terror barrier and then to
Freedom 98% of the world's people are
spending 98% of their time on things
that don't
matter that's true and things that have
nothing to do with why we're here yeah
we get caught up in our doing this oh
you don't understand I'm a
cameraman that's what I do I'm a I'm an
audio technician that's what I do now
you don't understand I I do interviews
you know I write books that's what I do
but those doing this functions are
meaningless unless they are ways to
demonstrate what we're really here to
accomplish mhm
and what we're really here to accomplish
is the fullest expression of who we
really
are people who step into
that
activity and come from that
awareness are people who change the
lives of everyone whose life they touch
just see love just see possibility just
see all the things that you've come
through and then I want you to speak to
yourself as as if you were your best
friend say your first name I would say
Lisa say your first name and then
complete these three sentences the first
sentence say your name first Lisa I
would say Lisa I'm proud that you and
find seven different things to celebrate
yourself for and they could be small
things Lisa I'm proud that you got out
of bed this morning I'm proud that
you I'm proud that you pray today I'm
proud that you went to work today I'm
proud that you set a healthy boundary in
that relationship I'm proud that you got
out of the relationship I'm proud that
you said yes even though you're afraid
to LEAP about that new job I'm proud
that you got on the phone today with
your mother whatever that small thing is
that you can celebrate they don't have
to be big huge things remember celebrate
the micro winds and the micro winds
become macro winds and you say I forgive
you
for go back 20 years go back 10 years go
back 5 years our go back 5 days Lisa I
forgive you for getting in a
relationship that wasn't worthy of you
Lisa I forgive you for lower your
integrity bar and saying yes when you
really should have said no Lisa I
forgive you for endangering gilani when
you got into an abusive relationship
unknowingly Lisa I forgive you for not
getting out sooner quicker faster Lisa I
forgive you for gaining over 80 pounds
being too stubborn to go to the doctor
to find out what was really
wrong Lisa I forgive you for blaming
yourself when a relationship didn't go
right and he left when in fact man's
rejection was really God's
protection but you blamed
you that second
sentence is liberating
sobering a little painful and definitely
freeing Lisa I commit to you that today
I will only say yes when I want to say
yes and I'll say no on the days that I
need to say no Lisa I commit to you that
I won't keep score I won't collect
evidence on why life won't work for you
our relationships won't work for you or
this next eating plan won't work for you
I won't keep track I mean I won't keep
score I won't collect evidence why it
won't work I'll keep track on why it
should work Lisa I commit to you that
today
I'll stop the negative chatter sooner
quicker faster and I'll go into the love
chatter sooner quicker faster in the
Riga 9th and 10th
mandelas there are hymns devoted to a
psychedelic called
Som so these practices have existed
since ancient ancient times what they do
is they take you beyond the dark alleys
and the ghost fill
attics and the secret passages of your
your
mind which bamboozles you into thinking
this is reality this is not reality this
is a projection of reality reality is
infinite possibilities infinite
creativity infinite correlation
synchronicity unpredictability
self-regulation self
Evolution
and amazing
imagination so by
loosening the neural correlates of the
Collective
mind which uh exist in our brain and
loosening the neural correlates of the
ego mind which is called the default
mode
Network or what you know aldus Huxley
called the reducing valve you enter a
totally different domain of awareness
you lose your fear of death you
understand your Universal nature and you
have the spont anous emergence of what
we call platonic values truth goodness
Beauty Harmony love compassion joy
equinity and if you're lucky lose the
fear of death because you realize that
your fundamental reality is not in space
time it is without cause it is spaceless
dimensionless and infinite Dimensions at
the same time it is timeless it is
irreducible it is fundamental it is
formless and it is infinite and it is
you the self of the individual is the
self of the universe there's no better
gift we can get to discover who we are
because once you find out who we are as
roomi said by God when you find yourself
you'll be the idol of yourself that's
how they work if you keep up with the
literature the scientific
research on self-regulation healing and
homeostasis then you've probably
heard of the vus
nerve the vus nerve is part of the
parasympathetic nervous system and the
longest and most important nerve in the
parasympathetic nervous
system it controls uh many involuntary
functions including heart rate breathing
digestion and immune
response so the vas nerve has been
considered uh the healing nerve of the
body the sympathetic nervous system is
responsible for the fight and flight
response the parasympathetic nervous
system for the rest
rejuvenate renew and healing response
these are part of our autonomic nervous
system the vagus nerve is the longest
nerve in our body it travels from the
midbrain and in turn is influenced by
eye movements because it interacts with
the ocular motor nerve it influences and
is influenced by facial
muscles it influences and is influenced
by tone of
voice it influences and is influenced by
breathing
by heart rate variability in influences
and is
influenced and it is also the nerve that
goes through the diaphragm interacts
with all the hollow organs of the body
all the solid organs of the body and uh
ultimately also influences the activity
of the
microbiome um bringing it to
self-regulation and remove removing
inflammation or disbiosis the vegus
nerve has bilateral
traffic
so we can activate healing um by vagal
activation actually ask
yourself am I having
Joy I found that our whole focus is on
Stress Management because it is the
biggest problem stress is the number one
pandemic
but is our life and our
Evolution such that work is the most
important thing do we want to go to to
our death ultimately saying I had a lot
of successful exits made a lot of money
but I never experienced Joy if you don't
have joy life is wasted so ask yourself
I ask myself every day am I experiencing
Joy am I hanging out with people who are
joyful otherwise I don't want to be with
them and are we together making other
people joyful those are the only three
criteria use and the rest follows so
make Joy the only measure of well-being
and success think about that Joy is the
only reason we're here just look at a
child before they're Bamboozled into all
these social
constructs they're joyful for no reason
and that's that's the way to be the past
is over it is nothing more than a memory
even though when we cling on to those
memories we experience trauma and
inflammation the
future in reality is a field of infinite
possibilities but that field of infinite
possibilities can only be tapped in this
present moment when we dwell on the past
or worry about the future we are taking
ourselves out of the present moment and
this can lead to feelings of stress
anxiety
unhappiness
so how do we realize the benefits of
living in the now when we are present in
the moment we are more likely to
experience joy peace and love we are
also more likely to be productive and
successful
so lots of things that you can do to
stay in the present moment one simple
thing you can do is be aware of your
breath focus on your breath when you're
feeling ex ex stressed or anxious take a
few deep breaths and focus on just the
sensation of breath another thing is to
pay attention to your
senses what do you see hear smell taste
and feel
focusing on your sensory experience can
help you to become more grounded in the
present
moment I also suggest mindfulness as a
very practical way to be present
metacognition be aware of the present
moment the experience in the present
moment as it's happening without
judgment observe yourself without
judgment as Krishna morti said the
highest intelligence is to be aware A
Ware of your own self to observe
yourself without judgment so meditation
yoga all help the past and future are
Illusions although they can affect us by
clinging on to that they can affect us
in the present moment
biologically and there are many benefits
of being present the present moment is
all we have by living in the now we can
experi the fullness and richness of Life
the question that was asked was how do
we maximize the use of our time here's
my answer and I learned this from Dr
Daniel seagull a US UCLA psychotherapist
he says divide the time in 24 hours into
the following sections so sleep time
meditation time exercise time
relationship time
downtime creative and play time focused
work time and when you eat and when
you're doing each of these things then
just do those things don't do anything
else I thought that was very brilliant
and I've been doing this now for a
number of years I sleep at least six to8
hours a day I meditate early in the
morning uh for about 1 and 1 half hours
I I go to the gym after that I walk
between 5 to 10 miles a day uh I work
from about 9:00 to 12:00 noon then I
take a full hour for a mindful
lunch uh I take a 20 minute walk after
lunch then I start working again in the
afternoon around uh you know 1:00 or so
1:30 2 even and then I do a short
meditation at 4:30 in the evening 5:00
and I have an early supper around 6:00
and I'm in bed by about 10: now when I'm
doing this daily routine then I feel
that my rhythms are in order they're
connected to the rhythms of the
cosmos and uh when I'm uh speaking to
someone I'm present with them I don't
check my iPhone or my handheld device at
the same same time because the cortical
brain can only do one thing at a time so
of course the autonomic nervous system
can do many things at a time uh do one
thing do it mindfully and do it well
pursue excellence and ignore success
stay
detached and divide your time into those
quadrants if you talk to great leaders
and this is well done research even by
Jim Collins if you read his book um he
says that every leader in the end says
one of the following things I was
lucky or I happen to be in the right
place at the right time there were a lot
of meaningful coincidences now if they
happen to be spiritual or religious they
may use expressions like God was on my
side I seem to be
guided um there was a state of grace at
times I was being looked after
what they're tapping into is a deeper
intelligence that goes beyond the
personal you might call it transpersonal
or you know as the transpersonal
psychologists call it or you might call
it archetypal if you're familiar with
the uh teachings of kalung but what they
do is they H they have a relationship
with the
story that's what a good brand is by the
way a brand is a archetypal story it has
themes in it the good guys the bad guys
there's a little bit of intrigue there's
mystery there's Adventure uh all the
ingredients that make a really good soap
opera and they have a relationship with
that and you know a good brand is
something that you'll buy or use the
service of but you're actually buying
the story apple is a story it's a very
great story you know and all the all the
big Brands Nike shoes it's the story of
the africanamerican urban hero you know
so when you I one of the things I tell
leaders to do is what's your story okay
can you make your story emotionally and
spiritually inspiring and you know
people will buy your story um as the
brand as the service as the product a
lot of people don't really relate
business and spirituality together you
don't really hear about it how do you
think it does work though do you think
you need that part I Define spirituality
as self-awareness and um also as
elements of compassion love
service honesty authenticity
Integrity I think uh even if you don't
relate to those values if you
incorporate those values your business
is going to thrive follow your bliss
does not mean get addicted to
pleasure okay follow your bliss means
finding the core of passion and
Excellence within you it is to pursue
excellence and ignore success and if you
do that of course success will be a
byproduct but you're expressing the
highest uh potential within yourself and
when you do that you lose track of time
you um uh experience
ecstasy and for when you express that
there's a need in society for that
particular expression
and when Society sees that it honors you
it makes you a
hero to stop killing your dreams watch
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there if I could give
people a takeaway to start with that's
really simple it doesn't mean there
isn't a lot of hard work at the other
end of it it would be be very clear on
what it is that you want spend 5 minutes
sitting down and visualizing those
things